[Music]
this is the greatest time to be alive
and you happen to be living in a great
place for my thesis you live in a place
where this country lives its life here
and the cost for you to enter it and do
something for yourself and your family
zero you got your perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you back how we doing Jakarta I
just flew 24 hours took a quick shower
plan on delivering this keynote a couple
of meetings and I'm heading to the
airport at 4:00 p.m. so a very quick
trip unfortunately this time but I'm
very excited about it and there's a
whole lot I want to cover so let me let
me create some context for some of the
people in the room who don't know as
much about me and then I'll go into the
reason why I genuinely believe as we all
sit here today together that because of
this device that many of you are holding
we are living in the most opportunistic
time ever to put yourself into a place
of happiness and happiness comes in all
forms and I think a lot of business and
entrepreneurship but I definitely want
to articulate today a framework that
speaks to how do you get happy because
of how much opportunity there actually
is let me take a step back I was born in
the Soviet Union in 1975 a little ways
ago I came to America
when I was three years old it was a very
challenging upbringing in the first
couple years you know six family members
in a studio apartment we struggled we
had to learn new language we started
from the bottom no question as you can
imagine my parents are very much my
heroes my mom stayed home and raised the
kids my dad worked every day many many
many hours a day first as a stock boy
putting bottles on the shelf in a liquor
store in New Jersey for only two dollars
an hour so very humble beginnings where
the vaynerchuk's come from
but entrepreneurship was definitely
foundational in the happiness that we
were able to create over that period of
time my dad worked quite a bit
eventually he became the manager of that
liquor store and that's when we moved to
New Jersey outside of New York City and
that's where I mainly grew up and that
is where my entrepreneurial career began
I am I always wanted to work you know
it's it came natural to me it's what I
wanted to do when the summer days
happened and all the kids wanted to play
I wanted to go wash people's cars I
wanted to sell lemonade I wanted to do
business
it was always in me it's what made me
happy when I was five six seven years
old I convinced all my friends to stand
behind booths from the lemonade that I
made and I would make signs and try to
think about how to market long before
the Internet I cared about one core
thing which was the attention of the
person that I was trying to reach and
how I could get them excited to buy my
thing eventually after lemonade I
started my first kind of real business
in America in the 80s baseball cards
sports cards that people could trade
became very very big and I rode that
wave I got very involved I loved sports
and I loved even more buying packs of
cards getting good cards and reselling
them and that's really where I learned
much I mean to think that sitting here
today and having so many people clap for
you in on the complete other side of the
world and so much of that was what I
learned in the malls and conventions in
New Jersey selling these cards it's
remarkable I'm very humbled I very much
appreciate the warm welcome when I came
out here and I'm setting up this
framework because I think you know as I
was getting ready for this conference
and I looked at so much of the chatter
about the conference and obviously the
phenomenal Instagram account
of our hosts and kind of just looked the
thing that the thing that I've become
fascinated about the thing that I want
to talk about today is really two things
literally right before I came out here
with the organizers they're like talk
about the how and I asked them I said
the how here or the how here what's
interesting to me now that I've been a
little older and had my career and I'll
go back to in a minute to frame it up
but as I'm segwaying what's interesting
to me is every wonderful person that I'm
looking at right now for them to get
what they want happiness forget about
money for a minute happiness for them to
get what they want it actually is only
one of two things here or here and here
represents doing the work knowing what
to do my whole career as I got more
known on the Internet
I did not want to be a motivational
speaker and I spent many years not
talking about this I mainly talked about
this but after a while what started
happening was I I started reading enough
comments because I read all my comments
and i just started realizing so much of
why people can't get there has to do
with this that I started talking about
it more over the last four or five years
but I think they both matter you could
be the most optimistic happy person up
here but if you don't put in the work
and if you don't know what work to put
in it's not gonna happen
optimism is very close to delusion
however I believe that optimism is the
fuel to practicality right if you don't
believe you're doing it for a reason or
it's exciting you're not gonna want to
put in the hours of the work and so
that's who I've always been I've always
been ambitious and happy I was very
fortunate I had a tremendous mother who
loved me very very much so I felt good
however she did not create entitlement
when I lost him when I was doing bad she
told me she didn't make a fake
environment which is a huge
actor and to be honest my biggest
concern about the last 20 years of
parenting too much fake environments too
much entitlement which is why so many
people struggle when they go into the
real world because the real world
doesn't care the real world is not your
mama anymore
and so I think about those things fast
forward I was very good at selling
baseball cards when you're making three
or four thousand dollars a weekend when
you're 14 years old you've got it I was
good at fine but then my dad eventually
bought a liquor store and he dragged me
into the liquor store when I was 14 I
started making 2 bucks an hour bagging
ice this was huge for me if I didn't
have that transition all the money I was
making as a young kid it came so easy
because I was naturally talented I think
not having that struggle of losing all
that because my dad forced me to work in
the store and making $20 a day I that
really helped me and I learned a lot in
that liquor store most of all what I
learned was to watch people today after
this talk I will go to the airport and
on my flight I will literally read most
of the comments on Twitter on Instagram
your DMS I will read them and I'll read
them to understand was there anything I
said in this hour that stood out that
didn't hit that did hit I learned that
watching people and more importantly
understanding people and most
importantly being empathetic to people
was the best way to build a real
business to build something meaningful
the biggest problem I'll tell you right
now one of the biggest reasons most
people in this room if they decide to
start an entrepreneurial venture a side
hustle whether you try to sell something
in your home on Facebook marketplace
which oh by the way I'm gonna bring up
later
my biggest belief that the quickest way
for many people here to start is to sell
stuff on Facebook marketplace but I'll
talk about that later whether it's that
whether you're finally ready to start
your podcast on Spotify whether you're
gonna build your Instagram profile or
mean page because you want brand dollars
whatever you're up to in this room the
reality is that if you
have to put in so much work but so much
of what comes out of people's mouths or
what they post is selfish not selfless
it's what you want you want them to buy
it you want them to like your post you
want them to follow you the biggest
reason I have the luxury of standing
here today is from the wine business to
the content I made on YouTube when it
first came out to everything I've done
over the last eight to nine years in my
books in all my free content I've always
thought how do I bring more value to you
than I get in return it's very simple
karma or doing the right thing always
works the problem is most people are
impatient the reason most people are
impatient especially in cultures like
mine Eastern European in cultures like
here there's too many people in here
that are trying to get successful too
fast because they want to prove it to
their parents and in that impatience is
a very important point
my friends the number one thing I fear
period is that people live their lives
based on other people's opinions the
number one thing that I have seen as
I've gotten older that has been very
obvious to me is that most of the people
here today do many of the things they do
because of one to five people's opinions
in their lives whether their parents
their spouse their older sibling their
neighbor living your life predicated on
the judgment of somebody else is the
great weakness of the human being the
biggest reason you know do you know many
people are here today just to get
affirmation from me to go and do
something I mean it I mean it and it's
fascinating to me and I am empathetic I
I understand and I want to talk about it
a lot because no matter how I tell you
how to
five hundred comments on Instagram posts
or what time to post your posts or why
you should start a spotify podcast
tomorrow or how you actually list an
item on Facebook marketplace no matter
what I tell you if you post the first
day and the person that you're worried
about has a bad opinion of it it's
already game over and so I flew all the
way here 24 hours to put pressure on
what is the most obvious conversation
which is are you prepared to finally get
quiet in your head and not allow the
opinions of others to dictate your
behaviors every person here knows what
they want to do if you're here today
there's something running through your
mind that you want to do there's no
reason for you to be here today unless
there's something running through your
mind that you want to do how many people
here are over 40 years old raise your
hands raise them high raise high don't
be scared raise high there's no Jesus
Christ this is a young crowd
[Applause]
for the very small percentage of us here
that are over 40 what thanks brother
there's like eight of us bro for like
the 11 of us look here here's this is a
lot of fun I'm for the 11 of us we lived
life before this we were grown
we were grown ups already before the
internet came I was 18 years old I'd
lived my life at least the childhood
part of my life without the internet the
biggest thing that excites me especially
in a mature internet market like here
whatsapp and Facebook and late and
Instagram and YouTube and Spotify like
there's so much opportunity and you
don't even have to leave your home there
was no building your life you know after
hours when I was growing up when you had
a job and you had to take care of
something you didn't then start another
job because it was late but now this
allows it the biggest thing that I want
to get across in this little moment of
this speech is everybody in here is
taking this for granted your
grandparents your great-grandparents
your great-great grandparents they
didn't have this if you aren't
succeeding or attacking your success
with this in your hand then what are you
doing every single person here has the
opportunity to create a profile and a
presence online whether it's yourself or
your business or your idea and the cost
is zero I love when people get mad when
Facebook or instagrams organic Reach
goes down I keep reminding them it's
free
how many people here are on Instagram
raise your hand Jesus over the next year
or two
instagrams reach is gonna go down
because more ads are gonna go in so as
you can imagine I'm so passionate to get
you to post three or four times a day
not once a day yet everybody over thinks
their posts so much cuz they're so
scared not to get as many likes as they
did last time it's true it's 100% true
the amount of people here who want to
post something but retake it fifty three
times or change the filter or things of
that nature or my favorite move you post
it but in the first eighty three seconds
you don't get enough likes and you
remove it it's a fascinating thing for
me to watch because what it speaks to is
in my opinion people being confused
about the game I view the game macro i
watch most people play micro you're not
in the business of getting likes on
Instagram yet you're pandering to the
Machine of that you're in the business
of creating awareness for whatever you
want you want people to know what you
want them to know whatever that may be
business raise money for a charity sell
something become a personal brand you
know whatever it might be whatever it
might be that's what you want yet people
get so caught up in the semantics listen
what I can tell you for my career is
this repeats over and over and over
again in 2006 I started one of the first
YouTube shows period it was the longest
show on YouTube when I launched it
YouTube wasn't even a year old i sat in
front of a camera and I drank wine for
30 minutes and a lot of people watched
it
a year later Twitter came out and I was
one of the first people to move on that
I invested because I got smarter at that
point but I also was one of the first
people to amass a million followers on
that platform before I did YouTube and
Twitter a year or two earlier in America
and many other parts of the world
myspace had won and dominated and there
were people that won on that platform if
you pay attention to what happened on
MySpace if you pay attention to what
happened on YouTube if you pay attention
to what happened on Twitter and then
Facebook and then vine and on and on and
on it's all the same game in the
beginning if you move quickly you can
get more attention most people get
frustrated that they aren't first and
then they don't go all in because they
think they missed it however winning on
these platforms is a game of being
better not first being better comes in
two ways this is where it gets very
important my friends getting being
better on putting out content only comes
out in two ways either entertainment
right or information if you are putting
out content on these web sites and
trying to grow you and you want to
succeed and build an audience you either
do information you know what you're
talking about
whether it's painting nails business
wine sneakers haircare I don't care what
it is you either know or you entertain
entertainment comes in a lot of ways
this is playing out on Instagram
entertainment comes in being funny
entertainment comes in being musical
entertainment and escapism comes in
being attractive being a model it all
plays if you're lucky enough to have
both it gets really crazy but if you do
not do one or the other you lose if you
go look at your Instagram account right
now and look at the last ten posts my
question to you is very simple did you
post those posts for your audience so
they could be entertained or informed or
you post it for yourself for your own
self-esteem or insecurities let me save
you time you posted it for yourself
the biggest takeaway that you could have
from here in my opinion is a couple
things number one you are very fortunate
to live in a country with
disproportionate advances on these
platforms when I look at the data of how
much attention is on this device and
those six platforms in this country and
the size of this country it is
staggering this is one of the best
places in the world to produce content
for YouTube Spotify Facebook Instagram
Twitter it's one of the best places in
the world as see you did it again you
clapped for yourself oh actually fun
fact actually back to this amazing place
and the internet and apps I don't know a
lot of you know this but I was actually
one of the first five investors in path
which was a huge app here for a long
period of time before it shut down a
year ago so because I was an early
investor in path and because this became
the biggest market for path four or five
years ago I spent a lot of time paying
attention to this market from far away
and what I can tell you is this the
beauty of the people that live here and
there's so much you know it's funny
there's so much amazingness you know in
the world that I see and it's see how
many people here consume my content
raise your hands
thank you so thank you so if you do you
have a good sense of me you can imagine
why I love Indonesia so much all the
love and optimism and warmth plays out
here but the biggest thing that I'm
passionate about is getting people to be
less insecure and care less about what
people think especially their parents
plays out here too and so for me it's a
really interesting market to look at
with friends and how people do things
and what they respond to and who they
follow and why and so what I can tell
you is if you are capable if you are
capable
to be strong enough internally to start
posting on these platforms more truth
more your truth you your truth you will
see a remarkable return on that
investment in this market now let's talk
about content because no matter what
you're doing in this room you're gonna
have to produce it to achieve what you
want the problem is there's a lot of
ways to produce content one of the
biggest issues that I'm excited to
address here is in a world where
Instagram does extremely well or YouTube
people think pictures and videos are the
only way to go I'm here to tell you that
two of the places I'm most excited about
are the written word and audio if you
are not comfortable taking tons of
pictures and videos you immediately have
to make a decision here today are you a
good writer and if you are I have a lot
of good news for you I'll go to that
minute or two if you like to talk
however you're uncomfortable with video
I couldn't be back to your clapping more
passionate about the last six months in
Indonesia the consumption of podcasting
in this country is exploding the the
unbelievable ease to produce a podcast
and distribute it in 2019 is remarkable
there's an app I've been talking about a
long time it just got bought by Spotify
called anchor you literally it's called
anchor you can download on your phone
you literally record on your phone you
press two more buttons and it puts it
all over to the different podcasts no
friction you could be doing it right now
so the excuse of I don't know how to do
it or how do I produce it or do I have
to go to the radio station and how do I
do nothing cost of entry zero friction
zero literally all you have to do is
Google how do I use anchor or download
it I highly recommend if you have
something to say about some category
I highly recommend getting very serious
about podcasts because I believe that
audio over the next decade is gonna be
one of the biggest ways we consume
because we don't like wasting time
humans love efficiency and audio saves
time audio is exploding and will
continue to explode and I highly
recommend you look at it seriously
another thing that's interesting to me
is actually a little tidbit I don't
share very often but I always say watch
what I do not what I say when I looked
at the hashtag or the comments for this
conference I looked at a bunch of
accounts the number one mistake I
believe people are doing on Instagram
right now is not leaving enough written
copy the number if you look at my posts
when I post a picture video on Instagram
I write a lot of copy I don't do that
for my health I don't like wasting three
minutes I do it because it matters so I
know a lot of you are trying to build
your Instagram one of the best hit bits
I can give you is please start adding
two three four five six seven sentences
to your post add context add clarity add
a little story you will see substantial
returns
speaking of written how many people here
are on LinkedIn raise your hands
quite a few if you're paying attention
to me you might have noticed literally
I've talked about LinkedIn more in the
last four months than I have in the last
seven years
LinkedIn's content business it's
business and even if you're a fitness
influencer there's a way to do business
content write an article six things a
traveling business woman and man can do
when they're in a hotel room so you
could always make your content fit
LinkedIn organic reach on content is
very high very high I highly recommend
everybody here get serious about their
LinkedIn I know a lot of you haven't
signed in in three years four years the
LinkedIn that many of us grew up with
was just to get a job it is now about
business content and I believe whether
again you sell rugs or sneaker
our wine there's a way to write content
for LinkedIn remember the mindset of the
person on LinkedIn is business so you
have to consider that it's different
than Instagram right LinkedIn is your
office
instagrams the club you know so you have
to act differently you have to act
differently but I'm telling you right
now
LinkedIn and Spotify podcasts for a lot
of this room that hasn't been making is
a very big opportunity posting 3-4 times
a day on Instagram is a very big
opportunity all this content that I want
you to write is a very big opportunity
content is how you will make your
happiness happen putting out content is
how you will make your happiness whether
that's build a big business whether
that's get a dream job a collaboration
content talking content is how you'll
make your happiness happen the problem
is I need you to look inside yourself
and tell me why you're not doing it to
me what I've learned in the last five or
seven years I can sit here for a half an
hour and give you every detail I can
tell you right now that if you go into
your explore page on Instagram and click
on every one of those videos and then go
leave a comment on that post a
thoughtful comment watch the video
picture not just hey or an emoji look at
it and spend two minutes and leave a
comment that if you do that 30 40 60 a
hundred times a day if you're hungry if
you're ambitious if you want something
if you do that I know that will work it
will work you will grow you will get
more attention you will get more
attention to your business to yourself
my question is why won't you do it my
question is why won't you do it will you
not leave a comment because you're
nervous to leave a comment on somebody
who's famous is page will you not leave
a comment because you think somebody's
gonna judge your comment will you not
leave a comment because you don't want
to spend an hour leaving comments why
for me everything is about
reverse-engineering
what do you want to happen like what
what do you want to happen and then
understanding in 2019
that written words audio and video on
seven platforms can get you there is
remarkable it's just remarkable it's so
crazy to me what's I'm sitting here
listening as I'm talking and I'm
literally blown away that I believe it I
mean it I'm shocked that we are now
living at a time where the Internet is
at scale the apps that dominate the
culture are free you could literally
walk out of here right now and start the
process of changing the course of your
life if you want and literally the only
thing left now because the excuse of
money and time is over that's amazing
the fact that money and time have been
subsidized by the internet because you
can lay in bed and do it at 11:00 p.m.
if you want and the cost is zero you
don't have to buy a store and open it
like zero it eliminates all your excuses
and now the question is why not why are
you not and so I'm very passionate of
getting this room today to start
thinking about what they want to be
doing and how and where and why I'm
breaking it down into audio written word
videos and pictures you know what the
five or six platforms are now it just
becomes the match to get it started and
more importantly and the biggest thing
that I fear will the group have enough
patience to see the results I was on
Twitter from 2007 to 2011 and I replied
to every single person that tweeted at
me and in the beginning because nobody
knew who I was I went to Twitter search
and I searched the word wine and other
wine terms found people talking about it
jumped into the conversation and left
good information I did that for seven to
eight hours a day for four years before
anybody gave a [ __ ] about who I was
let me let me say that slowly one more
time for seven to eight hours a day for
four years I would go to Twitter search
search wine terms jump into them and
give information for four years before
anybody gave a [ __ ] who I was now I get
DMS from people saying in three weeks
I'll get a DM from somebody here saying
Gary saw you in Jakarta it was awesome I
started doing stuff I'm not getting any
traction I reply
that's nice Mario you've been doing it
for three [ __ ] weeks the level of
pain let me let me take a real step back
if you're sitting in this chair and you
want to do something that makes you
happy and makes you money let's just say
that I have no idea what people want in
here but fine
how many people happy money raise your
hands if you want happy might raise it
don't be scared great let me ask you a
question if you have the audacity to be
happy and have money which by the way
the amount of people that have lots of
money and are very happy is very small
just if you want to be happy and have
money don't you think it should take a
long time and it should be hard right
that to me has been the most interesting
thing in this world that everything's so
fast and this world where one or two
people look like Mark Zuckerberg or
traveling where where you can point to
one or two people you know I don't know
if you heard there seven point seven
billion of us but because you can point
to one or two people that got it fast
and a lot all of a sudden everybody
thinks it should be fast and a lot at 34
years old after working for 12 years
helping build my family business I left
my family business and I had no money
34 no money how many people here younger
than 34 razor
d-roc where are you hold on keep them up
d-roc where are you
yo right here come here look at this put
the lights on hands up look at this
every hand here
stand up actually if you raise your hand
stand up every person here standing is
under 34 years old when I left Wine
Library day-to-day at 34 years old I had
nothing when I started vaynermedia we
started it in buddy media's conference
room cuz I didn't have dollars to spend
on rent
imagine how early I think you are in
your life you can sit thank you if you
can keep the lights on I like it thank
you beautiful thank you my friends
it's early it's early for 19 it's early
for a hundred percent of the people in
the room it's ridiculously early for
ninety five percent of this room this
internet thing it's big it's real big we
haven't even started
please understand how lucky that's the
only word I have for it how lucky you
are that you get to live during this era
right now anything that comes out of
your mouth that is complaining makes
your grandfather want to punch you in
the [ __ ] face you understand do you
understand how much better you have it
then every generation before you this is
such a ridiculously special time and
literally the far majority of this room
is not gonna take advantage of it
because of the insecurity of worrying
about somebody who they don't even know
leaving a comment that they're ugly are
you literally not gonna take advantage
of the actual ability to be happy and
successful because somebody comes on
your account and says you're stupid but
this is what's playing out this is
what's happening I mean look at
different cultures on the way here do
you know the
one of the biggest things that was
deemed here is that there's a lot of
people coming here by themselves and
they wanted advice how to say hello to
somebody that they didn't know what are
you scared of they're gonna bite you we
are living in a very fascinating time a
very fascinating time it reminds me of
when new countries are born and people
buy up real estate the attention the
attention of this room is real estate
you're trying to get in everybody's
living on these things it's gonna happen
more not less you can judge it that's
fine but that's what's gonna happen and
so if you are not producing words and
videos and sounds for these seven
platforms you almost don't exist now
what you say though matters very much
and let me give you a couple advice
points from somebody who's really one
the number one thing you have to always
do is talk about what you know I watch
people try to talk about stuff they
don't know every single day because it's
hot
whether it's cannabis or sports betting
or blockchain or social media people
start talking about things they don't
know anything about because they're
trying to grab they think they're gonna
get a fast score everybody wants a fast
score do you know many people have
emailed me crying about buying Bitcoin
at ten thousand a coin because it was
gonna be a hundred thousand and in a
year people are looking for fast scores
you know many people here spent $800 on
a course because it was gonna happen
fast fast is bad fast is bad fast if you
have talent and the right intent is
amazing fast if you want cash
immediately so please please please
understand the world you're living and
take it into context understand how
remarkable this era is next this is the
most important word you have to deploy
self-awareness my friends self-awareness
is the most important word if you don't
know who you are you have no shot but do
not be a bad
rest of who you are when I knew that I
was an entrepreneur in the 80s
I got D's and F's in school and that was
not acceptable in the 80s and 90s in
America if you were a bad student in
America in the 80s and 90s you were a
loser my friend's parents looked at me
looked at me as I was a loser but I knew
who I was I was self-aware I knew that I
was an entrepreneur I wanted to go and
sell things on the weekend I wanted to
study the prices of wine and baseball
cards instead of studying for school I
knew who I was playing video games
seemed like a waste of time 20 years ago
now there are people who make 50 million
dollars a year playing video games if
there is something you know and you like
and you're passionate about but it's not
cool right now or important do not
deviate away from your thing triple down
on your thing the other thing is be
self-aware how many people here are an
entrepreneur or want to be raise your
hands I'm just curious
it's a lot of hands the reality is most
of you can't be successful I mean that
I'm not saying it to razz it's rare to
be a successful entrepreneur it's hard
it's a real talent we don't think it's a
talent now because it's so easy to say
you're one one of the most important
things about being self-aware is knowing
do you have the stomach to be an
entrepreneur putting entrepreneur in
your Instagram account easy living the
life of an entrepreneur where nobody
else is on the line except you hard
lonely scary difficult if you do it
because it's cool or you think it's
right or you're not self-aware it leads
to depression and loss of money if you
deploy self-awareness and realize you're
a number two a number three and number
four you find an entrepreneur and you
win self-awareness you have to
understand who you are without it you're
a massively vulnerable in society and
the fact that we now live in a world
where you're more than welcome to be
what you are so much more maybe not in
your family because your parents want
you to be
doctor and a lawyer and an engineer but
in the world yes and so I highly
recommend self-awareness
it is easily in my opinion I believe
that self-awareness and the ability to
actually give without expectation are
the two bricks of happiness and it's
been a big factor for me which is
allowed me to go fast when you're stable
you can go fast because you're not
worried about judgement I've been able
to do a lot of things because I'm not
scared to lose because if I lose it's my
loss if I lose money or time it's my
loss not yours I don't care what you say
in the comments that lack of fear is
what gives an entrepreneur an advantage
that lack of fear is what lets somebody
live life in happiness we have to start
having more important conversations of
the operating system of your life
there are people here that work more on
upgrading their phones than upgrading
their minds I mean it I mean it I am
desperate listen to come here all this
way to talk about tactics is a waste of
time to come to all this way and have
one person in here gain actual courage
to do something is super worth it and
for me it's a very simple game let me
give a very big secret to all the kids
here who are living their lives for
their parents or based on their parents
judgment there's a very big secret that
parents never tell you if you go the
other direction of where they want you
to go and you become really successful
they are really proud and make pretend
they never pushed you in the other
direction
[Applause]
the number one thing I fear and the
number one thing I learned and this is
very interesting to me i'ma tell you
story I don't tell a lot when I was a
little kid in Edison New Jersey when
grandparents came over I would go play
with the grandparents a lot a lot maybe
it was cuz I lost three of my four
grandparents as a kid but even as I get
goose bumps right here on stage it's cuz
I think I've always been filled with a
lot of wisdom and old soul it's just DNA
it's nothing I did it just been in me
but I was always gravitating towards old
people my whole life I mean really old
you know I'm seven eight years old I see
an 80 year old I run over sit next to
them and talk my whole life I loved it
my whole life and the number one thing I
learned in the first 20 years of my life
spending more time with old people than
most kids is the biggest thing I fear is
regret regret is scary resentment is
very scary the biggest reason I push
kids to do what they want versus what
they parents want is because I'd rather
them and their parents have five or six
or seven years of bad than 80 because it
gets very ugly when you're 60 and
they're 80 and you lived your life based
on what they wanted and now you resent
them it gets real ugly real fast
I would rather you have the pain for the
next five or six years of fighting and
then have one of two things happen which
I think both are amazing
number one you were right you were right
and you are an amazing fashion designer
not an engineer and you built a real
company and your parents are going to be
very very proud or you were wrong you
suck at fashion design nobody liked it
but at least for yourself you never have
to live the rest of your life asking
yourself what if you win both ways you
live in a culture I know I watch you
live in a culture with a lot of expect
patience you live in a culture where
parents treat their kids as a property
that indicates who they are so does most
of the world this is not a Southeast
Asia thing this is not a Indonesia thing
this is a world thing parents are
insecure too and they like their kids
closing their gap we have to start
talking about this because now that it
costs zero to start a spotify podcast
now that you can do that at 9 p.m. now
there's nothing left in 1974 not having
money in time was an excuse in 2019 it
is not and so the only thing left is
this not this this and so I come here
today begging not pleaing
not asking begging you to look yourself
in the mirror tonight and ask yourself
if you're happy and people would say I
don't know what my passion is I don't
know what I would do yes you do you do
you just don't think it would work you
think it's too small
you think it's too silly you think
people would judge you you know you're
just scared to say it you know exactly
what you would do if you could do it
every minute of your life you may not
right now as I'm saying this you're like
no I don't Gary I don't it's because you
haven't even allowed yourself to look
this is the time to build businesses and
profiles and content around what you
enjoy this is the time this is the time
and waiting one more day makes no sense
to me
so whether you use the momentum of the
energy we created today or something
else
please don't get older and regret please
don't watch this exact video on whatever
YouTube is in 35 years
you want to hear something weird
everybody in here right now is actually
watching this right now in 35 years
everybody here right now is actually
gonna watch this exact talk on video on
the internet and 35 years and I'm gonna
ask you did you [ __ ] up or no I mean it
I mean it because what I'm interested in
is did you understand what I was saying
here today and do something about it
or do you do what so many people do do
you know what I watch every day i watch
people see a video clip of mine on
Instagram or YouTube or Facebook or what
have you
leave a comment that that was the clip
that was changed their life right it
feels very nice oh my god this just
changed my life I'm gonna do it but I'm
weird you know what I do I follow them
and sometimes especially on trip like
this when I'm in the air for 24 [ __ ]
hours I will go and look and see six
months nine months a year later if they
did anything about it
at 99% don't there's a lot of people in
this room right now that said this is it
I'm going to
I see you and then in two and a half
weeks all the Energy's gonna be gone and
I spend every day thinking about that
how do I one of the biggest reasons I
produce so much content as I used to
speak a lot but then there wasn't as
much content so I thought okay maybe if
I put out content eight times a day it
can get them going I've come to learn
and I very much believe this I was
gifted and parented very well that
allowed me to actually not care about
other people's opinions I respect them I
never think I'm always right this is not
about thinking you're right this is not
about me being delusional or audacious
this is me understanding that if you
judge me you don't have all the context
you don't know me so how do I know you
I don't even the person closest to you a
spouse a parent they don't know nobody
knows so why would you take somebody
else's opinion over your own please my
friends don't live a life that gets you
to 80 90 100 years old where you're
sitting there and saying I wish I did I
wonder if I did nobody at 90 years old
go find your oldest relative and go take
them out to lunch and ask them just like
this talk to me about life they will not
talk to you about what they did they
will talk to you about what they did not
do they will talk to you about what they
wish they did don't wish they had an
excuse your grandparents your
great-grandparents it wasn't practical
you couldn't do what we can do this
didn't exist huh
this did not exist please take advantage
please take advantage of this existing
this is the greatest era to be alive it
is there's plenty going on in the world
plenty going on in my country plenty
going on in the world but when you look
at the macro data this is the greatest
to be alive and you happen to be living
in a great place for my thesis you live
in a place where this country lives its
life here and the cost for you to enter
it and do something for yourself and
your family
zero zero dollars I do not want to hear
that you don't have money I don't want
to hear that somebody else is further
along because nobody else's life matters
this is an inside game inside start
making content start talking to the
world about what you either like or you
know do it every day close your eyes for
five years not how are you doing in five
days not how you're doing in five months
five years I come back here in five
years or I see you in an airport in five
years and you say every day I made five
pieces of content and I went nowhere I
would say two things number one I'm
proud of you that was a long time number
two you clearly suck because if you're
putting out things for five years and
nobody gives a [ __ ] your stuff sucks
please please I hope Jakarta you heard
me today everything on the platforms you
know you know which ones people use you
use them your friends use them you don't
need that information what you do do
need to do is take a step back and don't
think that video and pictures are the
only way I do think audio and written
word for a lot of people here matters by
the amount of hands that went up for
Entrepreneurship I think a lot of people
here have to look themselves in the
mirror and ask who they really are are
you self aware about your skills but
leading into what you're interested in
and producing content has never been
more practical and I implore you I
implore you to take advantage of this
very special time because you have one
life you might as well live it thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
QA I know we're gonna do some QA but
Shelby's a girl please give it up for
Gary Vee Davey
yes sir thank you for being here thanks
for having me it was really good
thank you we have a QA after this so if
you can just sit down to my right okay
we have a few questions from the
audience member that we have chosen from
our social media okay
yes so without further ado our first
question comes from Alexander is
Alexander here
what up Alexander I'm good okay thanks
thank you so much for let's clap it up
for Alexander thank you for the plants
that you give me in that so let's make
me wakes up I run a small branding
agency you have one yes okay
they'll help fashion fashion brand
designer local to get them the better
logo better brand identity and better
campaign understood what I want to ask
is should I learn all the skill I mean
be a general is that so yes so I can see
the bigger picture I focus on one yeah
that makes me that make these specialist
or expert no I'll tell you why you're
too young and you how will you know if
you decide right now to be an expert
just on Instagram organic creative let's
say that how do you know that you're not
the most talented strategist around
Spotify growth of podcast until you
become a generalist
do you even know which thing to become
an expert in but you understand
Alexander like like
you're [ __ ] a kid no that's good you
know you don't know yet what you're best
at like why are you picking your
expertise if you haven't seen everything
else you should go in it's like food I
love when people like Gary I like I like
eating exotic food so sometimes I'm in a
meeting and I'm not and I'll order
Easter's or sea urchin or whatever I
order and I go D and my dinner person
will be like well I don't eat I don't
like oysters I'm like well have you ever
had an oyster no and that's how I think
about this you need to understand ads
and media and ads and creative and
Spotify and Instagram and LinkedIn you
have to taste everything you may think
in streams delicious until you actually
taste LinkedIn you need to be a
generalist first then you can tell me
what you're an expert in thank you
you're welcome
can you go through the next question
please
all right the next question comes from
maybe eyes Fatima is she here okay
awesome
hi Jenny how are you hi fine thanks
Florida opportunity
I'm ad okay so I might me and my spouse
have a photography and videography
agency and my both of our parents know
don't do business at all they work from
8 to 5 so they kind of not believing in
us right and then after 2 or 3 years we
started to think that we may need an
investor after two or three years you
what we might need an investor okay so I
want to know from you because you have
already invested in many things as an
investor what is the most crucial thing
you see in the business you're going to
invest in what's what makes you invest
in them so for me when I look at
investing there's only two things I care
about one do I generally believe in the
idea or the concept and and I I and then
two and more importantly do I believe in
her or him and they're capable to drive
it I've lost a lot of money as an
investor in the last 10 years 15 years
when I loved the idea so much and I
could figure out what I would do with it
but the person running the business
wasn't capable and I learned from that
so now it's 51% 51% you 49% the idea or
the concept that's what I look for but I
think more importantly because I want
you to be successful you need to find
invent what startups here need to do or
businesses you have to find investors
who are most likely to invest in you I
see so many people wanting to get money
from the cool VC or a bank and they're
never gonna get it you need to find the
investor that's gonna invest in you and
a lot of times that's somebody that did
what you did before and they understand
it so as a start-up look for investors
that are most likely to invest in you
don't be ideological about where the
money's coming from as long as you're
getting
money you know makes sense okay thank
you you're welcome
all right our last question comes from
bent Arthur it's been Arthur in the
building there years hey Gibby
what up then good I'm a fan man
I'm a fan too Ben so I'm gonna ask what
is the best the best financial decision
that have made you and shaped you today
the best financial decision I ever made
was never spending more money than I had
go figure
and and what I mean by that bet I and I
appreciate the reaction because that
means it's a very smart crowd I am
fascinated that people buy things they
can't afford to impress people they
don't like
[Applause]
yeah man like from a practical
standpoint right back to your question I
think being aggressive is important when
I when I met Mark Zuckerberg for a drink
many years ago it took me two seconds
and I mean two seconds and I knew he was
gonna win and so when I went home and
had an opportunity a year later to buy
stock from his parents right I spent all
I took 90% of the money that I had saved
in a bank and I invested it right and
that was a great decision obviously for
me but I didn't take 200% I didn't go
borrow money things of that nature I
took a risk but it was a risk I could
afford here's why if I was wrong and it
went to zero all that would have meant
was I couldn't eat as fancy or maybe go
as fancy on a vacation but it didn't
mean I was going out of business and too
many people here take big risks that
they can't afford without thinking about
what happens when you go to zero I'm
very aggressive and I do a lot but I
never take myself below zero I'm willing
to go to zero because I'm not fancy
I don't need stuff but I'm never willing
to go below zero
keep that in mind we have time for one
more question yeah so this is open to
everyone if you have a question raise
your hand up
[Music]
who's got the mic yeah okay that crazy
[ __ ]
he's all hyped what's your name let's
start with that
I have to question I have very your my
others in Iowa was in college back in
when I was in school at University of
Indonesia Faculty of Law and I really
want to take a photo with you may what
is said in here and in here I couldn't
hear it say one more time
may I take photo with you a photo yeah
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're not gonna freak
welcome everybody gives you pulled off a
round of applause for Gary me I love you
listen go do it
please don't let this energy go away one
[ __ ] life live it please live it go
work thank you beyoncé's to come up on
stage for a photo session thank you